j'ai été voir un spectacle de shia
c'était le spectacle
avatar il ya cinq ans et ben ça m'avait
beaucoup plu et j'ai voulu essayer de
faire de la danse avec elle et je suis
resté depuis la professeur de danse
allait super c'est c'la meyer une
professeure de danse apprécié dans une
association qui fête ses dix ans
l'association manic oise éducatives et
culturelles prépare un spectacle
rétrospective de cette décision
des nouveautés aussi ce qu'ont fait pas
que des anciens morceaux mais on a
sélectionné
les meilleurs enfin pour nous dans ce
qu'on a fait jusque là en 2009 ils
étaient trois à lancer cette association
elle compte aujourd'hui une cinquantaine
de danseurs de tous les âges
l'association fait essentiellement c'est
des spectacles de danse que l'on fait
des activités aussi culturelles ont fait
les capitales européennes
cette année on est parti à berlin il ya
deux trois ans on était parti à londres
avec est un projet qui a été monté de
toutes pièces par les ados
le spectacle c'est ce samedi 29 juin à
17 heures et à 20 heures 30
la couturière s'adapte au style de la
chorégraphe la street dance
s'il demande à chaque fois de voir les
chorégraphies cas-là proposé pour
pouvoir créer les costumes ils s'étaient
donné rendez vous dans dix ans et les
voici sur scène pour fêter cela
ils vous attendent pour ce show
anniversaire à la maison de
l'environnement